Do four-day weeks work?
When French company boss Laurent de la Clergerie...
...decided to let his staff work a four-day week...
...on the same pay as before,...
...some people took him for a crazy person.
But a year on, his LDLC company selling consumer technology...
...has increased annual turnover by 40 percent...
...without hiring any extra staff.
As the world emerges from a global health crisis...
...that prompted many people to reevaluate their work-life balance,...
...companies and workers around the world are asking an important question.
Can they work less?
De la Clergerie says before he embarked on the change,...
...he did the math.
LDLC employs approximately 1,000 people.
He worked out that even in the worst-case scenario,...
...the change would add to labor costs by at most 1.6 million dollars per year.
It was a manageable risk he was willing to take.
Since then, he said that absenteeism and sick leaves have gone down.
The company has also not had to hire new people...
...to offset the reduction in hours worked.
And although the four-day week is not the only factor,...
...De la Clergerie says it contributed to a jump in turnover...
...from around 550 million dollars before the change to nearly 770 million dollars.